Lindsey Dills is 24. She's from a place in southern Georgia called Glynn County, right on the coast. The nearest big town is a partly gentrified, mostly impoverished city called Brunswick. Population 16,000. Though I interviewed her in a prison way upstate.
林赛·迪尔斯今年24岁，来自佐治亚州南部海岸边的一个地方，叫格林县。附近最大的城镇是一个既有士绅化倾向又大多贫穷的城市，叫不伦瑞克，人口16000。不过，我是在州北部的一所监狱里采访她的。
OK I'm Lindsey Dills. This is Lee Arrendale State Prison. Before all this I was-- I actually was all-state for soccer five years in a row. I was expected to have a scholarship to college. A couple scouts had contacted my dad, my coach at my school.
我是林赛·迪尔斯。这是李·阿伦代尔州立监狱。这一切发生之前，我其实连续五年入选了足球全州明星队。本来大家以为我能拿到大学奖学金。有几个球探甚至联系过我爸爸，他也是我学校的教练。
But in her sophomore year of high school, Lindsey started smoking pot. She began working at this bar and restaurant, Spanky's, as a waitress, ran with an older crowd that she met at the restaurant. By senior year she was doing coke in a pretty serious way. She had a 21-year-old boyfriend, which at the time she thought was the coolest thing ever, though now she sees that one differently. Finally, senior year, she quit soccer, which of course, her dad and every other adult in her life tried to talk her out of.
但高二那年，林赛开始抽大麻了。她在一家叫“斯潘基”的酒吧餐厅当服务员，和在那儿认识的一群年纪较大的人混在一起。到了高三，她开始严重吸食可卡因。她有个21岁的男朋友，当时她觉得这酷毙了，不过现在她对此有了不同的看法。最终，高三那年她退出了足球队，当然，她爸爸和生命中所有的成年人都试图劝阻她。
The coaches were calling the house, telling my dad, "Will you please talk to her?" And probably part of it was part of the drugs, and I think part of it was that I just had done it for so long and I wanted to be-- I wanted to be a teenager. I wanted to go do stuff on the weekends, and I wanted to not have practice at 5 o'clock in the morning. And I didn't want to have to run three miles every other day.
教练们打来电话告诉我也爸爸：“你能劝劝她吗？”这可能部分是因为毒品的原因，但我认为部分原因是我踢得太久了，我想当个十几岁的孩子。我想在周末出去玩，不想在凌晨5点训练。我也不想每隔一天就去跑三英里。
And she says, in retrospect, she knows she wasn't coping well. Her home life had been pretty rough when she was little, before and after her parents split up. And now she was self-mutilating, cutting herself with a razor, smoking a lot of pot. And her parents tried to do the right thing and get her treatment for all that. She went into a program for a week or so, more than once. But here's where things took an unusual turn for Lindsey. October 2004, she was 17, her dad was out of town. And she forged two checks, one for $40, one for $60, on her dad's checking account. She cashed them at her job, spent some of the money on drugs.
她说，回过头来看，她知道自己当时应对压力的方式很糟糕。她小时候的家庭生活相当艰难，父母离婚前后都是如此。那时她开始自残，用剃须刀割伤自己，抽大量的大麻。父母试着做正确的事，给她找了治疗。她不止一次住进过一周左右的康复项目。但林赛的生活在这里发生了一个不同寻常的转折。2004年10月，她17岁，父亲出差了，她在父亲的支票账户上伪造了两张支票，一张40美元，一张60美元。她在工作地点兑现了它们，把一部分钱花在了毒品上。
Well, he comes back from out of town and he does his balance his checkbook. He's a CPA, so he's on it. As soon as he gets home he knows that something's not adding up. And I don't-- I don't in a million years blame my dad for doing what he did. He was terrified. All he'd heard was horror stories about what happens to people when they were doing drugs. He didn't mess with drugs. My dad doesn't drink. In the 24 years I've been alive, I've never seen my dad drink alcohol. I never heard my dad curse.
他出差回来后开始核对支票簿。他是注册会计师，所以很仔细。他一回家就知道账对不上。我并没有——我这辈子都不会责怪我爸爸所做的事。他当时很害怕。他听到的全是关于人们吸毒后会发生什么的可怕故事。他不碰毒品。我爸爸甚至不喝酒。在我活着的24年里，我从未见过我爸爸喝酒。我也从未听过我爸爸说脏话。
She says he started randomly taking her to be drug tested. And told her that if she failed a drug test, then he'd go to the police about the two forged checks. Lindsey figured out ways to pass the test-- get somebody else's pee, or dilute her own. But finally she fails a test. And her dad followed through on his threat.
她说，父亲开始随机带她去做药检。并告诉她，如果她药检不合格，就会去警察局告发那两张伪造的支票。林赛想办法通过了测试——弄来别人的尿液，或者稀释自己的。但最终，她还是没能通过。父亲兑现了他的威胁。
Two police officers come into my job and they're like, "We're looking for Lindsey Dills." I was like, "Let me get her for you." And I'm about to just leave. So I know exactly what's going on at this point when they say, "We're looking for Lindsey Dills." I was like, "Oh my god, he actually did it." I never thought he would do it.
两名警察来到我的工作地点，他们说：“我们在找林赛·迪尔斯。”我说：“我去把她叫来。”我当时就想溜。当他们说“我们在找林赛·迪尔斯”时，我完全知道是怎么回事了。我当时想：“天哪，他真的这么做了。”我从没想过他会真的报警。
So I am arrested at this point. They slam me over the hostess stand. I'm at the front of restaurant. People are turning around. I'm mortified. I'm, like, 18. And everybody's just like, "Oh [BLEEP]." Because they know how my dad is. My dad used to call Spanky's to see if I had left work. He's be like, "Is Lindsey there?" Because I would be like, "Oh, I'm working late."
所以我被捕了。他们把我按在招待台上。我当时在餐厅前面。人们都转过身来看。我太丢脸了。我才18岁。每个人都在说：“哦，该死。”因为他们了解我爸是什么样的人。我爸以前经常打给“斯潘基”看我是不是下班了。他会问：“林赛在那儿吗？”因为我以前经常说：“哦，我在加班。”
The sheriff's in there. He's one of the regulars at the bar. And the sheriff's standing there Like, "Oh my god."
治安官也在那儿。他是酒吧的常客。治安官站在那儿说：“天哪。”
Because you know the sheriff, because you've waited on him.
因为你认识治安官，因为你接待过他。
Right, I know the sheriff. And then there's a bond salesman there that, he's a regular. Him and the sheriff are real good friends. And so he finds out what my bond is, and he's going to bond me out, because he's familiar with me. Well, my dad calls him. Because I'm like-- my dad's like, "I'm not going to bond you out." I was like, "Well, I don't need you to bond me out. So and so's bonding me out." It's the worst thing I could have ever said. So my dad calls this man and begs him not to bond me out. He's like, "Please don't. I'm trying to save her life."
对，我认识治安官。还有个保释金推销员也是常客。他和治安官关系很好。他打听到我的保释金是多少，并打算帮我交保，因为他认识我。结果，我爸打给他了。因为当时——我爸说：“我不会帮你交保。”我说：“好，我不需要你帮我交保。某某会帮我交的。”这是我这辈子说过最糟糕的话。所以我爸打给那个人，求他不要帮我交保。他说：“求你了，不要。我在试图挽救她的生命。”
Her dad declined to be interviewed for the radio. But Lindsey's mom, Vikki Woodard, confirmed that he was hoping that this would be the intervention that would change everything. She had moved from Georgia to South Carolina a month before Lindsey forged the two checks and kept in touch by phone with what was happening. She says her thinking was, Lindsey had just turned 18. It was their last chance. After this--
她父亲拒绝接受电台采访。但林赛的母亲维基·伍达德证实，他当时确实希望这能成为改变一切的干预。在林赛伪造两张支票的一个月前，她就从佐治亚州搬到了南卡罗来纳州，并通过电话了解发生的事情。她说她的想法是，林赛刚满18岁。这是他们最后的机会。过了这个阶段——
She could do whatever she wanted. She could drop out of school. She could move out. We would have no influence over her whatsoever. And she was in a fast spiral down at that point. She was not going to school. Her father would call me and say, "I can't get her out of the bed in the morning. She just won't get up." And so he rolled the dice.
她想做什么就能做什么。她可以退学，可以搬走。我们对她将毫无影响力。当时她正处于快速堕落的漩涡中。她不去上学。她爸爸打电话给我说：“我早上根本叫不起她。她就是不肯起床。”所以他孤注一掷。
He rolled the dice hoping that she would agree to a drug treatment program that he found, out of town, away from her friends and everybody who was influencing her to do drugs, and that she'd go there in exchange for dropping the charges. But Lindsey didn't want to go out of town to some drug treatment program that her daddy picked. And then the prosecutor put another option on the table. Drug court.
他孤注一掷，希望她能同意去他找的一家外地戒毒中心，远离朋友和所有影响她吸毒的人，并用戒毒换取撤诉。但林赛不想去她爸爸选的什么外地戒毒所。接着，检察官提出了另一个选择：毒品法庭。
Drug courts are all over the country. You've probably heard of them. They've been around since 1989 and they are a huge national success story. The idea is, you take nonviolent offenders whose crimes are caused by their drug addiction. And instead of prison time, you give them court supervised drug treatment. This accomplishes two things. It saves money, because fewer people are incarcerated. And studies show it actually helps people. It gets them off drugs, which means fewer repeat offenders.
全国各地都有毒品法庭。你可能听说过。它们从1989年就存在了，是一个巨大的国家成功案例。理念是，对待因毒瘾而犯罪的非暴力罪犯，不判入狱，而是给予法院监督下的戒毒治疗。这能实现两件事：一是省钱，因为入狱的人少了；二是研究表明这确实能帮助人们。这能让他们戒掉毒品，意味着累犯减少。
But if you enter a drug court program, it's serious business. Especially the drug court that happened to be in Lindsey's small town. Which is run by a judge that many people truly fear. The Chief Judge at the Glynn County Superior Court, Amanda Williams.
但如果参加毒品法庭项目，那可是非常严肃的。特别是林赛所在小镇的毒品法庭。它由一位许多人真心害怕的法官运营：格林县高等法院首席法官阿曼达·威廉姆斯。
The basics of the Glynn County drug court program are about as tough as they get. It takes two years to complete. And at the beginning, you're going to five meetings a week with drug court counselors, plus four AA or NA meetings a week, plus curfews and drug tests every week. If you finish the whole program, your record is wiped clean, but if you mess up and flunk out, you have a felony conviction on the original charge on your record and you serve the time for that conviction. So there's a real threat hanging over your head.
格林县毒品法庭的基本要求非常严苛。完成需要两年时间。起初，你每周要参加五次毒品法庭辅导员的会议，每周还要参加四次戒酒互助会（AA）或戒毒互助会（NA），加上每周的宵禁和药检。如果你完成了整个项目，犯罪记录会被清零；但如果你搞砸了并被淘汰，你的档案里会留下最初的重罪记录，并且要为该罪名服刑。所以你头上始终悬着一把剑。
So Jason Clarke is my public defender at the time, and he's warning me. He's saying, "Lindsey don't take drug court. I'm telling you, you won't make it." He's told me this like three or four times. I'm adamant. I'm saying, "I'm taking drug court." Because all I know is I get to get out of jail. It's all I know. I don't know anything else about it. So I go to plead into drug court. My dad's in the courtroom. Judge Barton was on the bench that day instead of Judge Williams. She was gone. My dad's done Judge Barton's accounting for probably the past 15 years and they're very good friends. So he sees me come in and he pulls me up to the bench and he's like, "Don't do this. Don't take drug court. Are you sure you want to do this?" He asked me three or four times.
当时杰森·克拉克是我的公设辩护人，他在警告我。他说：“林赛，别进毒品法庭。我告诉你，你坚持不下来的。”他大概跟我说了三四次。我非常固执。我说：“我要进毒品法庭。”因为我只知道这样就能出狱。别的我一概不知。于是我去认罪加入毒品法庭。我爸也在法庭上。那天坐在法官席上的是巴顿法官，而不是威廉姆斯法官。她不在。我爸过去15年来一直负责巴顿法官的会计工作，他们是非常好的朋友。所以他看到我进来，把我叫到法官席前说：“别这么做。别进毒品法庭。你确定要这么做吗？”他问了我三四次。
Judge Barton says this?
巴顿法官这么说？
Judge Barton does this. Judge Barton's trying to talk me out of taking drug court, that I would not do well. I wouldn't make it. He didn't think it was what I should do.
巴顿法官确实这么做了。巴顿法官试图劝我放弃进毒品法庭，说我不会表现得很好，坚持不下来。他不认为这是我该走的路。
And she was spiteful that day.
那天她心怀恶意。
Again, Lindsey's mom, Vikki.
又是林赛的母亲维基。
She was like, "You--" And Lindsey's just got a little bit too much of her dad and I in her. She's very independent. She's like, "You're not going to tell me what to do. You want me to do this? I'm doing this other thing." She clearly looked at her dad. He said, Vikki, she looked at me with the most spite and hate in her face that he'd ever seen. And she was like, "I choose drug court." And he could not believe it. He said his heart fell into his stomach and that he was just stick.
她说：“你——”林赛身上有太多我和她爸爸的影子。她非常独立。她说：“你没法告诉我该做什么。你想让我做这个？那我偏要选另一个。”她明确地看向她爸爸。他说，维基，她看向我的眼神里充满了她见过的最深的恶意和仇恨。她说：“我选毒品法庭。”他简直无法相信。他说他的心沉到了胃里，整个人都僵住了。
And he had told me just the other day on the phone, his voice was breaking, he said, "I wish-- I think about it over and over again in my head and, I wish I had stood up on that day in court." He regrets more that day than I do, I think.
他前几天在电话里跟我说，声音都在颤抖。他说：“我希望——我脑子里一次又一次地回想那天，我希望那天在法庭上我能站出来阻止她。”我想他比我更后悔那天发生的事。
That's because Lindsey happened to be at a very unusual drug court. Most drug courts, you're in and out in a year or two. The average program is a year and three months. Occasionally, very, very rarely, somebody is stuck in a drug court for three years. But the drug court run by Judge Amanda Williams operates so differently from others that Lindsey will spend five and a half years in drug court, including 14 months behind bars. And then she's going to spend another five years after that. Six months behind bars-- she's in the middle of that right now-- and four and a half years probation. By the time she's done, it'll be 10 and a half years of her life.
那是因为林赛恰好在一个非常不寻常的毒品法庭。大多数毒品法庭，一两年就出去了。平均项目周期是一年零三个月。偶尔，非常非常罕见的情况下，有人会陷在毒品法庭三年。但由阿曼达·威廉姆斯法官运营的毒品法庭运作方式与其他法庭大相径庭，林赛将在毒品法庭待上五年半，包括14个月的监禁。在那之后她还要再过五年：六个月的监禁——她现在正处于这个阶段——还有四年半的缓刑。等这一切结束时，她人生中的十年半都搭进去了。
Now that seemed like a lot to me. Remember, the original crime here is two forged checks totaling $100. First offense. But I thought, maybe that's just how they do it in Georgia. So I ran it by two lawyers who handle drug cases around the state.
这对我来说看起来太多了。记住，这里的最初罪行是两张总额100美元的伪造支票。初犯。但我心想，也许这就是佐治亚州的办事风格。所以我找了两位处理全州毒品案件的律师确认了一下。
That's insane. That is complete insanity.
这太疯狂了。简直完全是疯了。
This would be Bruce Harvey, a defense attorney who's handled felony drug cases for 33 years all over Georgia. Here's Parag Shah, who was a public defender in Atlanta, author of a guide book to Georgia criminal law called The Code.
这是布鲁斯·哈维，一位在佐治亚州各地处理了33年重罪毒品案件的辩护律师。这是帕拉格·沙阿，亚特兰大的前公设辩护人，也是佐治亚州刑法指南《法典》的作者。
Wow. That is-- my opinion would be that would be egregious in probably 90% of the counties in Georgia.
哇。我的观点是，这在佐治亚州可能90%的县里都算是过分了。
That seems like a lot.
这听起来太多了。
Extremely.
极端多。
Both attorneys said that typically two forged checks for $100 bucks, first offense, at most would get your probation. And you'd probably get some sort of alternative program, like a 16-week drug class or a life skills class, without ever going to trial. Of course these were defense attorneys. Maybe prosecutors would see this differently. So I ran the facts of Lindsey's case by the District Attorney for Forsyth County, Penny Penn, who handles the drug court cases there.
两位律师都表示，典型的两张伪造支票共100美元，初犯，顶多就是缓刑。而且你可能会被安排参加某种替代项目，比如16周的毒品课程或生活技能课程，甚至不用受审。当然，这些是辩护律师。也许检察官会有不同看法。所以我把林赛案件的事实情况带给了福赛斯县的地方检察官佩妮·佩恩，她负责那里的毒品法庭案件。
It certainly sounds rather Kafkaesque, doesn't it? And I don't know that it's a very good use of resources. And that's separate and apart from just the fundamental fairness.
听起来确实挺卡夫卡式的，不是吗？而且我不知道这是否是对资源的高效利用。这还没算上根本的公平性问题。
What's the fairness issue?
公平性问题是什么？
Well, that it has gone on for so long. You know, and the point of the drug court program is to get people help.
嗯，那就是这事儿持续了太久。你知道，毒品法庭项目的初衷是帮人。
WBEZ Chicago. It's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show we have a story about the kinds of court cases that almost never make the news because the offenses are so small. Two checks forged by a teenager, tiny instances of drug possession or attempts to purchase. But these cases have life-changing consequences because they're being adjudicated in what is possibly the toughest drug court in the country.
芝加哥WBEZ电台。这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目讲述的是那些几乎从未出现在新闻中的案件，因为罪行太小了。一名十几岁少年伪造的两张支票，微小的毒品持有或购买尝试。但这些案件却带来了改变人生的后果，因为它们正在全国最严苛的毒品法庭中被审理。
There are over 2,400 all over the United States. They give enormous power to judges. You sign away all kinds of rights when you enter the programs. This is the story of what happens when a judge takes that power and starts doing things other drug courts don't. Things that violate the basic philosophy of all drug courts. After months of investigation I believe that it's likely no other drug court judge in the country is running a program like Judge Amanda Williams. Stay with us.
美国各地有超过2400个这样的法庭。它们赋予了法官巨大的权力。进入项目时，你签署了各种权利放弃书。这是关于当一名法官接手了这些权力并开始做其他毒品法庭不做的事情时会发生什么的故事。那些违背所有毒品法庭基本准则的事情。经过几个月的调查，我相信很可能全国没有其他毒品法庭法官像阿曼达·威廉姆斯法官这样运营法庭。请留在我们身边。
Before we go any further, there's something that's going to affect what you hear this hour. It was unusually hard for me to get people to talk to me for this story. Over and over I would hear about something that Judge Williams had supposedly said or done, and I was go to the lawyers or litigants involved, and they'd refuse to speak with me, saying they were scared of retaliation. Which to be fair, would probably happen around lots of judges all over the country. In Glynn County, though, it was widespread. Ex-employees of the court, people who'd come up before the judge on divorce proceedings or other business years ago, parents and family members of people who went before Judge Williams. Nobody wanted to cross her.
在我们继续之前，有些事会影响你这一个小时听到的内容。我找人谈这个故事的过程异常艰难。我一次又一次听到关于威廉姆斯法官涉嫌说过或做过什么的事情，当我去找相关的律师或当事人时，他们都拒绝跟我说话，说他们害怕报复。说实话，这在全国各地的许多法官身边可能都会发生。但在格林县，这种情况很普遍。法院的前雇员，几年前因离婚诉讼或其他业务出现在法官面前的人，威廉姆斯法官曾经的当事人的父母和家人。没人想惹她。
I was able to get Judge Williams to sit down for an interview. It was this fall. She was up for reelection. A small group of lawyers had organized against her, tried to get her voted off the bench. It became a very contentious, bitter race. Even in an interview setting, she's imposing. Forceful, very quick, very smart. And she's idealistic. She told me that her interest in starting a drug court in Glynn County wasn't just to make the courts run more efficiently. It was personal.
我最终设法让威廉姆斯法官坐下来接受了采访。那是在今年秋天。她正竞选连任。一小群律师组织起来反对她，试图把她投票赶下法官席。那场竞选变得非常激烈、尖刻。即使在采访现场，她也很有压迫感。强有力，反应很快，非常聪明。而且她很有理想主义。她告诉我，她在格林县发起毒品法庭的初衷不仅仅是为了让法院运行更高效。这是私人的。
There's some addiction in my family. My husband has been in recovery for over 15 years. And about the time that I started looking to start a drug court, around 1996, he had gotten into recovery. So we've lived it as a family. Because all the family members are touched by it.
我家里有人有成瘾问题。我丈夫戒毒已经超过15年了。大约在我寻找发起毒品法庭的时候，也就是1996年左右，他开始戒毒了。所以我们全家都经历过这些。因为所有的家庭成员都会受到触动。
To nobody's surprise, Judge Williams won reelection this fall. It's notoriously difficult to unseat a sitting judge. She had massive name recognition after 20 years on the bench, and she outspent the other candidate 3 to 1.
毫无意外，威廉姆斯法官在秋天赢得了连任。让在职法官下台是出了名的难。她在法官席上工作了20年，拥有极高的知名度，而且她的竞选支出是对手的三倍。
But by this winter, Judge Williams's opponents were still digging around for dirt. Things were still incredibly divisive in town, and everyone was sure that more challenges for the judge were still on the way. And I assume because they felt so embattled, so unfairly attacked, drug court staff, counselors, and lawyers all declined my repeated requests for interviews. They acted like people under siege. The head of the counseling program, Steven Mansfield, after not returning my calls or emails, finally told me in the reception area of his office that he wouldn't take part in the story. I asked him why, and he repeated, "I won't take part in your story." I asked, "Do you first want me to explain what the story's about?" And he said, "If you try, I'll call an officer and have you removed from the building."
但到了这个冬天，威廉姆斯法官的反对者们仍在挖掘她的黑料。镇上的分歧依然令人难以置信，每个人都确信法官将面临更多挑战。我假设是因为他们感到腹背受敌，受到不公平攻击，毒品法庭的工作人员、辅导员和律师都拒绝了我反复的采访要求。他们表现得像是被围困的人。戒毒辅导项目负责人史蒂文·曼斯菲尔德在没回我的电话或邮件后，最终在办公室接待处告诉我不参与这个故事。我问他为什么，他重复道：“我不会参与你的故事。”我问：“你需要我先解释一下这故事是关于什么的吗？”他说：“如果你试着说，我会叫警察把你赶出这栋楼。”
Unfortunately when I interviewed Judge Williams this fall, I only ran through the issues that had come up in the judicial election campaign. Since then, I've sent her my tentative conclusions about what I see in her drug court. I listed the ways in which it seems unlike other drug courts around the country and asked for an interview about those differences. But after I phoned, faxed, emailed, and simply sat in her office day after day hoping to catch her, she had her secretary turn me down.
不幸的是，今年秋天我采访威廉姆斯法官时，只讨论了司法竞选活动中出现的问题。自那以后，我把我在她毒品法庭中观察到的初步结论发给了她。我列出了它看起来与全国其他毒品法庭不同的方式，并要求就这些差异进行采访。但在我打电话、发传真、发邮件，甚至日复一日地坐在她办公室门口希望能堵到她之后，她让秘书拒绝了我。
The main way Judge Williams's drug court is different from other ones is that it is simply more punitive. Take what happened to Lindsey. The week after she signed up for drug court she was caught violating the drug court's curfew on a Friday night. She also failed a drug screen. This is not unusual. Most people entering any drug court program relapse in the first few months. It's expected and built into the programs. Lindsey ended up in front of Judge Williams the following Wednesday.
威廉姆斯法官的毒品法庭与其他法庭最大的不同在于它单纯更具惩罚性。看看林赛身上发生的事。她在加入毒品法庭的一周后，被发现在一个周五晚上违反了宵禁。她药检也没过。这并不罕见。大多数进入毒品法庭项目的人在前几个月都会复吸。这是预料之中的，也是项目内建的一部分。林赛在随后的周三出现在威廉姆斯法官面前。
So she's telling me she still thinks I'm smoking pot, which I probably was. And so I had-- she like reams me out. Tells me that I'm like-- I just remember being in drug court. My face turned blood red. She was screaming at me. I started crying. I  had to go do seven days.
她跟我说她还是觉得我在抽大麻，这我可能确实在抽。所以我不得不——她把我臭骂了一顿。告诉我，我——我只记得在毒品法庭里。我的脸涨得通红。她在对我尖叫。我开始哭。我被迫去关了七天。
Seven days in jail, that is.
指在监狱里关七天。
And then from then on, the only time I ever interacted with Judge Williams was when I was in trouble. And she would flip out every time I went before her. I mean, she was just-- she's screaming at you in court. I mean, she's standing behind the bench with a microphone and screaming at you.
从那以后，我和威廉姆斯法官仅有的互动就是在我惹麻烦的时候。每次我在她面前，她都会崩溃。我是说，她简直是——她在法庭上对你尖叫。她是站在法官席后拿着麦克风对你尖叫。
Judge Williams has a reputation for yelling from the bench. When the new District Attorney, Jackie Johnson was sworn into office by the judge this August she joked, "Judge Williams heard my first trial. And of course, she yelled at me." I talked to one former drug court counselor who told me he actually quit over this. They'd see the judge lash out at clients, embarrass them and scold them. He came to feel that it was counterproductive, that what the addicts heard was the old punitive message that they were failures and worthless. It set them back. He eventually felt that he couldn't, in good conscience, be part of it.
威廉姆斯法官以在法官席上大喊大叫闻名。今年8月，当新任地方检察官杰基·约翰逊由法官主持宣誓就职时，她开玩笑说：“威廉姆斯法官审理了我的第一次审判。当然，她对我吼了。”我采访了一位前毒品法庭辅导员，他告诉我他实际上是因为这个辞职的。他们会看到法官对当事人发火，羞辱他们，斥责他们。他觉得这适得其反，成瘾者听到的是陈旧的惩罚性信息，说他们是失败者，一文不值。这让他们倒退了。最终他觉得自己凭良心不能再参与其中了。
In the court transcript the day that Lindsey's talking about, March 30, 2005, Judge Williams says, "Don't come up here and tell me you're not drinking. I will put you in jail another 24 hours every time you tell me you're not drinking. I know you're drinking." Lindsey then says something that's inaudible to the court reporter. Judge Williams replies, "You're drinking. You're drinking. Do you understand that you cannot drink?" Lindsey says, "Yes, ma'am." Judge Williams says, "OK, you're drinking and I personally think that you're using marijuana." This goes on for awhile and she says, "Now you give me seven days." Before Lindsey goes, the judge warns her, "Don't come in here and pull this addiction mess with this court."
在林赛提到的那天——2005年3月30日的法庭记录中，威廉姆斯法官说：“别上这儿来告诉我你没喝酒。只要你再说你没喝酒，我就让你再多关24小时。我知道你在喝酒。”林赛随后说了一句法庭记录员听不清的话。威廉姆斯法官回答：“你在喝酒。你在喝酒。你明白你不能喝酒吗？”林赛说：“是的，法官大人。”威廉姆斯法官说：“好，你在喝酒，而且我个人认为你在用大麻。”这持续了一会儿，她说：“现在你给我去关七天。”在林赛走之前，法官警告她：“别进我这儿来搞这种毒瘾把戏。”
Lindsey gets seven days for her first relapse. The standard penalty in Judge Williams's courtroom is less. If you fail a drug screen and don't admit to using drugs, it's three days the first time you relapse, seven days the second time, 28 days the third time.
林赛因第一次复吸被关了七天。在威廉姆斯法官的法庭上，标准处罚要更重。如果你药检失败且不承认吸毒，第一次复吸是关三天，第二次是七天，第三次是28天。
Any drug court that relies primarily on jail, or punishment generally, is operating way outside of our philosophy and just does not understand addiction.
任何主要依赖监禁或普遍惩罚的毒品法庭都完全偏离了我们的理念，根本不了解成瘾。
This is West Huddleston, who runs the National Association of Drug Court Professionals, the main organization for 25,000 judges, lawyers and counselors in the nation's 2,400-plus drug courts. He's been working with drug courts since the mid-'90s. He used to be a counselor and a coordinator for one. He says the problem with jail time is that decades of experience shows it doesn't work with addicts. Addicts keep using no matter what terrible things happen to them as a result of using. It's practically the definition of an addict.
这是韦斯特·赫德尔斯顿，他运营着全国毒品法庭专业人员协会，这是全国2400多个毒品法庭中25000名法官、律师和辅导员的主要组织。他从90年代中期就开始与毒品法庭合作。他曾经是一名辅导员和项目协调员。他说监禁的问题在于几十年的经验证明它对成瘾者无效。无论成瘾者因吸毒遇到多么可怕的事情，他们还是会继续使用。这简直就是成瘾者的定义。
They've lost jobs. They've lost their income. They've lost their loved ones. All of those natural consequences, which are much more severe than a day, or two, or three in jail have not stopped them from using drugs and alcohol. Why would we think that putting them in jail would do so?
他们丢了工作。失去了收入。失去了亲人。所有这些比在监狱里待上一两天、三天要严重得多的自然后果，都没能阻止他们吸毒和酗酒。我们为什么会认为把他们关进监狱就能做到呢？
And so when drug courts use jail time-- and the majority do-- he says it's very sparingly.
所以，当毒品法庭使用监禁时间——大多数确实会使用——他说这也是非常谨慎的。
You know, 12 hours, 24 hours.
你知道，12小时，24小时。
And only after other sanctions have failed. The official National Association for Drug Court Professionals' guidelines lists seven other possible things courts can do before they resort to jail, including warnings, increased treatment or monitoring, fines, community service, having to watch a whole day of drug court proceedings. The whole point of drug court was to be an alternative to what they called the punitive approach taken by the rest of the criminal justice system, and to replace that with treating and curing the addicts.
而且只有在其他制裁手段失败后才会这样。全国毒品法庭专业人员协会的官方指南列出了在诉诸监禁前法庭可以做的其他七种可能的措施，包括警告、加强治疗或监控、罚款、社区服务、旁听一整天的毒品法庭诉讼。毒品法庭的全部意义在于成为所谓刑事司法系统其余部分所采取的惩罚性方法的替代选择，并以此取代它，转而治疗和治愈成瘾者。
Now to be fair to Judge Williams and her drug court, I should point out the while jail time for first relapses might be unusual in drug courts around the country, it's not unusual in Georgia. Calling around, we found that these counties and judicial circuits all do it: Gwinnett, Dublin, Atlantic, Eastern, Forsyth, Cherokee, Enota, Dekalb, Waycross, Hall. Most of these counties, it's just a day or two in jail on first relapse. And none of them came close to the amount of jail time Judge Williams prescribes for later relapses and broken rules. Lindsey ends up doing jail stays of 51 days, 90 days, 104 days, which would be unheard of in most drug courts.
现在为了公平起见，对于威廉姆斯法官和她的毒品法庭，我应该指出，虽然第一次复吸就判入狱在全国各地的毒品法庭可能不寻常，但在佐治亚州并不罕见。我们打电话查了一下，发现这些县和司法巡回区都这样做：格温内特、都柏林、大西洋、东部、福赛斯、切诺基、埃诺塔、迪卡尔布、韦克罗斯、霍尔。在大多数这些县，第一次复吸通常只是关上一两天。而且没有任何一个县在后续复吸和破坏规则后的监禁时间能接近威廉姆斯法官开出的量。林赛最终经历了51天、90天、104天的监禁，这在大多数毒品法庭中是闻所未闻的。
And Judge Williams takes people who relapse four times and sends them away on what she calls "indefinite sentences." I could find no other drug court in Georgia that does this, and none of the national experts I talk with have ever even heard of such a practice. I learn details of how it works through interviews, court documents, and court depositions.
而且威廉姆斯法官对于复吸四次的人，会把他们打发走，判处所谓的“无期徒刑”。我在佐治亚州找不到其他任何毒品法庭这样做，我交谈过的全国专家甚至从未听说过这种做法。我是通过采访、法庭文件和法庭证词了解到它是如何运作的。
An indefinite sentence is just what it sounds like. Judge Williams sends you to jail, but doesn't specify how long it's going to be. Often that's because she hasn't decided. I was told that Judge Williams would declare things like, "They're going to sit their ass over there till they get a better attitude." Or, "Take them away. You'll come back when I'm ready for you." So you sit in jail  and wait, not sure what's going to happen to you next. Usually it's two or three months, but it can be more.
无期徒刑听起来是什么样就是什么样。威廉姆斯法官把你送进监狱，但不指定要关多久。通常是因为她还没决定。我被告知威廉姆斯法官会宣布诸如“他们要在那里坐着，直到他们表现出更好的态度”之类的话。或者，“把他们带走。等我准备好见你了你再回来。”所以你就在监狱里坐着等待，不确定接下来会发生什么。通常是两三个月，但可能更久。
At the end of all this, some people are kicked out of the drug court program, some are allowed back in. Some are sent to inpatient rehab facilities. Though the problem here, I was told by a drug court insider, was that, contrary to national drug court guidelines, Judge Williams first punishes the person for at least 28 days in jail-- and usually it's months-- before they're sent anywhere for more treatment.
所有这一切结束后，有些人被踢出了毒品法庭项目，有些人被允许回来。有些人被送往住院康复机构。不过，这里的麻烦是，我被一位毒品法庭内部人士告知，违背全国毒品法庭指南的是，威廉姆斯法官会先对当事人处以至少28天的监禁——通常是几个月——然后才把他们送到任何地方接受进一步治疗。
Lindsey Dills got sent away to indefinite detention on October 8, 2008. She'd been in the program for three and a half years at that point, had relapsed a couple times, done all sorts of things where you can understand they'd be kind of fed up with her. There's no court transcript of what the judge said that day, because rather than sentence Lindsey in open court like usual, for reasons that aren't clear--
林赛·迪尔斯在2008年10月8日被送去接受无期拘留。那时她已经在项目中待了三年半，复吸过几次，做过各种让你理解他们为什么会对她感到厌烦的事情。法庭没有那天法官所言的记录，因为她没有像往常一样在公开法庭上对林赛判决，原因尚不清楚——
She doesn't do me in front of everyone else. She has me go back into her chambers with her and the drug court staff. So we're in private now. There's no one that can hear any of this being said, and she's telling me how she thinks she should terminate me.
她没有当着所有人的面处理我。她让我和毒品法庭工作人员一起回到她的内室。所以我们现在是私下交流了。没有人在场能听到这些，她正在告诉我她认为她应该终止我的项目。
Terminate her, kick her out of the program. Which would mean serving the full sentence on the original forgery charges, 20 to 24 months.
终止她，把她踢出项目。这意味着要服完最初伪造指控的全部刑期，20到24个月。
I was hysterically crying this whole time. Because I'm like, "Oh my god she's going--" And I'm back in the chambers, completely by myself. I have no idea what's about to happen. And she's telling me how she's been thinking about terminating me, how she doesn't know if I can get this. That maybe I just need to go to jail and maybe I'll get it sometime later in my life, that they have other people to deal with. So she says, "You're going to give me 28 days.
我当时全程都在歇斯底里地哭。因为我在想：“天哪，她要——”我被关在内室里，完全孤身一人。我不知道接下来会发生什么。她正在告诉我她一直在考虑终止我，说她不知道我是否能理解这一切。也许我只是需要去坐牢，也许我以后什么时候能想通，他们还有其他人要处理。所以她说：“你要给我关28天。”
So I get to the jailhouse and I call my dad immediately as soon as I get there, from the pay phone that's in the booking area. And I hear the phone ring where the booking area is. And they answer it, and I heard them say, "Dills." Like, they were talking to someone and they said something about Dills. So I'm on the phone and they said, "Dills hang that phone up." And I'm like, "OK." And so I turn around, and the tell me that Judge Williams has now called and ordered me to have no further contact: no phone, no visitation, and no mail. And that I'd be put in their isolation cell. And I'm like, "How long?" And they're like, "We don't know." And I'm like, "Well for the whole 28 days that I'm here?" And they said, "Well your order is now indefinite."
于是我到了监狱，我一进去就立刻从登记区的投币电话打给我爸爸。我听到登记区那边的电话响了。他们接了，我听到他们说：“迪尔斯。”好像他们在和某人说话，提到了迪尔斯。所以我还在通话中，他们说：“迪尔斯，挂掉那个电话。”我说：“好的。”我转过身，他们告诉我威廉姆斯法官刚才打电话下令禁止我再进行任何接触：没电话，没探视，没信件。我会一直待在隔离牢房。我问：“多久？”他们说：“我们不知道。”我说：“是吗？在我待这里的整个28天里？”他们说：“你的命令现在是无期的。”
So I don't know what to do. I'm thinking she's just going to leave me there for 28 days like this to really just scare the crap out of me. And then she's going to let me out. Well, 28 days comes and goes and I'm still sitting there. I don't know-- no one's come to see me. No one's told me what's happening. And then I also am on antidepressants at this point, prescribed by the drug court doctor, Dr. Cox, that I've run out of 28 days into my visit and I'm not allowed to call or tell anyone that I'm out of medication. So now I'm coming off antidepressants. I'm taking Cymbalta and Seroquel, and I'm detoxing from both that I've been on for over a year. I have no way to fill a new script or tell anyone that I need any more meds.
所以我不知道该怎么办。我以为她只是会把我在那里关上28天来狠狠地吓唬我一下。然后她就会放我出去。好吧，28天过去了，我还在那儿坐着。我不知道——没人来看我。没人告诉我发生了什么。而且此时我还在服用毒品法庭医生考克斯医生开的抗抑郁药，我在监禁第28天时药吃完了，我还没法打电话告诉任何人我药断了。所以我现在正在经历抗抑郁药的戒断反应。我吃的是欣百达和思瑞康，我正在戒除这两种我服用了一年多的药。我没有任何办法去补开新处方或告诉任何人我需要更多的药。
You can tell the guards, right?
你可以告诉警卫，对吧？
Yeah. I did tell the guards. I told medical. But they can't do anything. They can't fill the script within the jail.
是的。我告诉了警卫。我告诉了医护。但他们什么也做不了。他们没法在监狱里开处方。
Her isolation cell was just a regular cell in the middle of the normal cell block. Four walls and a door. And sometimes other participants in the drug court would relapse and wind up in that cell block.
她的隔离牢房只是普通牢房区内的一个普通牢房。四面墙一扇门。有时毒品法庭的其他参加者也会复吸并最终落进那个牢房区。
I'm screaming through the door that I'm behind. Like, someone from drug court will holler up at me. And I told people leaving that were going to drug court to tell drug court, please just let me get my medications back. And no one ever comes and sees me.
我在门后尖叫。毒品法庭的人有时会冲我大喊。我告诉那些要离开去参加毒品法庭的人，让她们告诉毒品法庭，求求他们让我恢复服药。但从来没人来看我。
I was in the same dorm as her. But I wasn't in lock down.
我和她在同一个宿舍区。但我没被禁闭。
Brandi Byrd was another drug court participant in the Glynn County jail at the same time. She had also worked at Spanky's, though not at the same time as Lindsey.
布兰迪·伯德是当时也在格林县监狱的另一名毒品法庭参加者。她也曾在“斯潘基”工作，不过和林赛时间错开了。
The cell next to hers, me and some of the other girls would go in there and talk to her through the wall, through the air vents.
她隔壁的牢房，我和其他女孩会进去，隔着墙、隔着通风口跟她说话。
How do you do that?
你怎么做到的？
You just stand up on the toilet or the sink and get to the air vent and talk through it and they can hear you. Ask her if she was OK.
你只要站在马桶或水槽上，够到通风口，隔着它说话，她们就能听见。问她还好吗。
They're not even allowed-- they're not really supposed to talk to me, these other inmates aren't. But I'm telling them, hey will you tell Gail to come see me to tell me what's going on-- my counselor-- they were going back to drug court. Drug court's telling them don't worry about me. They know where I am.
她们甚至不被允许——她们其实不应该跟我说话，这些其他囚犯。但我告诉她们，嘿，能不能告诉盖尔来见我，告诉我发生了什么——我的辅导员——她们会回到毒品法庭。毒品法庭告诉她们别担心我。他们知道我在哪儿。
I just check on her. Are you OK? Do you want my grandma to call anybody for you? Do you want something to eat? All she got to eat was the regular jail food, which is awful. So we'd slide her some ramen Noodles or some Kool-Aid or something under the door and try not to get caught.
我只是去看看她。你还好吗？你想让我奶奶帮你给谁打个电话吗？你想吃点东西吗？她只能吃普通的监狱食物，很难吃。所以我们有时会偷偷给她塞点拉面或者酷爱饮料之类的，尽量不被发现。
And how'd she seem?
她看起来怎么样？
She was very, very depressed. That's why we kept checking on her. She was really depressed.
她非常非常抑郁。所以我们才一直去看她。她真的很抑郁。
I cried a lot. Pretty much all the time, I was crying. I was like, how is this happening? How is this ethical? Where am I? Am I in a foreign country? Have I killed someone that I don't know about? Like, how does what I did merit that type of treatment? But there's nothing I can do about it, because I can't even use the phone. I can't even send a letter.
我哭了很多。几乎一直都在哭。我在想，这怎么可能发生？这符合道德吗？我在哪儿？我在外国吗？我杀人了但我不知道吗？我做的那些事怎么值得这种对待？但我无能为力，因为我连电话都不能打。我连信都写不了。
Weeks went by. Lindsey had no idea what was going to happen or when it was going to happen. Her public defender, Jason Clarke, was no longer with the drug court. And no other public defender came to check on her, she says. She also says that no doctor and no counselor from the drug court ever checked on her.
几周过去了。林赛根本不知道会发生什么，也不知道什么时候会发生。她的公设辩护人杰森·克拉克已经不在毒品法庭工作了。她说，没有其他公设辩护人来查看她。她说毒品法庭的医生和辅导员也没人来看过她。
I'm like, "Where do they do this?" I've never heard of it, and if it's even legal. And why isn't my family doing anything?
我在想，“他们为什么这么做？”我从没听说过这种事，甚至不知道这合不合法。为什么我的家人什么都不做？
The family, without Lindsey knowing, was trying to get answers from the drug court counselors about when she'd be coming out, about what the plan was, what was happening. Nobody tells them anything, they say. Lindsey's mom, Vikki, up in South Carolina, says as soon as Lindsey went into detention they were told that the judge put her in isolation, that she couldn't have contact with anybody, including the family.
林赛不知道的是，家人一直在试图从毒品法庭辅导员那里打听她什么时候出来，计划是什么，发生了什么。他们说没人告诉他们任何事。林赛在南卡罗来纳州的母亲维基说，林赛一被拘留，他们就被告知法官把她单独隔离了，她不能与任何人接触，包括家人。
At that point in time I said something to Johnny. I said, "I have a good mind to go to the newspaper and tell them what they're doing to our child." And he said, "Oh, Vikki, you cannot do that. You don't Amanda Williams and the power she has down here." He said, "It's gotten worse since you've left." And he said, "You cannot do that."
当时我对约翰尼说。我说：“我有种冲动想去报社，告诉他们他们正在怎么对待我们的孩子。”他说：“噢，维基，你不能那么做。你根本不了解阿曼达·威廉姆斯和她在这儿拥有的权力。”他说：“自从你搬走后，情况更糟了。”他说：“你不能那么做。”
Because why? How could it be worse than your kid locked up indefinitely with no contact from the outside world?
为什么？还有什么比你的孩子在与世隔绝的情况下被无限期关押更糟糕的事情呢？
That it could be indefinitely longer. That she could make things really difficult for Lindsey.
可能会被关得更久。她可能会让林赛的日子更难过。
I kept thinking, there's no way she'll leave me here on Christmas. Typically when she leaves you indefinite you stay about 90 days, is what usually you'll see. So I'm thinking, there's no way that she's going to leave me here like this though Christmas. So December 8, someone came to jail from drug court on a sanction and they said, "Oh, well Judge Williams isn't having court again till January." She was gone. She'd gone out of town. She does it every December. She's not even going to be back until like, January 6. So this is the 9th and so I'm just like, I can't do it anymore. I'm completely a wreck by this point. I haven't seen any other human besides the people that come bring me food. And I'm not that stable anyway. And I can't figure out how this is helping me. So I'm like, "Whatever, she's going to send me to prison and I can't do prison."
我一直觉得，她绝不可能让我在圣诞节还待在这儿。通常她判无期拘留时，你一般会待上90天，这是你通常会看到的。所以我心想，她绝不可能让我在圣诞节还这样。于是12月8日，有人因违反规定从毒品法庭被送进监狱，他们说：“噢，威廉姆斯法官要到一月份才开庭。”她走了。她出城了。她每年十二月都这样。她甚至要到1月6日才回来。今天是9号，我真的受不了了。我整个人彻底崩溃了。我没见过除了送饭给我的人以外的任何人类。我也本身就不太稳定。我想不通这怎么是在帮我。所以我想，“随便吧，她会把我送进监狱，但我受不了监狱。”
So that night I'm like, "I can't do this anymore." We had a new officer on duty that doesn't know that when you get your razor you're supposed to give it back.
那天晚上我想，“我实在受不了了。”我们有一个新值班的警官，不知道拿到剃须刀后应该还回去。
You mean like a little Bic razor, that kind?
你是说那种小必克（Bic）剃须刀吗？
Yeah. The little one blade in them. Like you buy, disposable razors. But I just broke it and took the blade out.
对。那种带单刀片的。就像你买的一次性剃须刀。我把它拆开，取出了刀片。
I have 15 minutes to use the razor. And then she came around to serve dinner. When she still didn't ask for it back, I realized at that point she wasn't going to. And then I slit my wrists and sat on the floor by the door. And they did a round 20 minutes later. Which is earlier than they normally would have done it. But she was changing shifts. And then that was when they found me. And then--
我有15分钟的时间用剃须刀。然后她过来发晚餐。当她还是没要求还回去时，我意识到她不会再问了。然后我就割了手腕，坐在门边的地板上。20分钟后他们查房。这比他们通常的时间早。但她在交班。他们就是在那时发现我的。然后——
Was your thought, I'm going to do this in a way where I get out of here? Or is your thought, I'm going to do this in a way where I'm dead?
你当时的想法是，我要用这种方式逃出去？还是你的想法是，我要用这种方式死去？
I actually hoped that I would die. But at the point that I figured then, well if I die, great. If I don't, at least someone will freakin' hear me. They'll have to send me somewhere. You know what I mean? They'll have get me some type of help.
其实我当时希望我能死。但我想，嗯，如果我死了，太好了。如果我不死，至少有人会听到我的声音。他们将不得不把我送到某个地方。你知道我的意思吗？他们必须给我提供某种帮助。
And then the doctor that came in to do the stitches was like, "I can't believe y'all gave this girl a razor in the first place. How would you think that someone would feel staying in there like that? Like they're animals?" And he was like, "Who ordered this?" And they said, "Judge Williams." And he like, I remember him cussing her name up and down in the room. He was like, "I'm calling her myself." Duh duh duh.
然后来缝针的医生说：“我真不敢相信你们竟然给这个女孩剃须刀。你们是怎么觉得一个人待在那儿会感觉如何的？像动物一样吗？”他说：“谁下令这么做的？”他们说：“威廉姆斯法官。”我记得他在房间里对她骂骂咧咧的。他说：“我要亲自打给她。”
He said, "I can't believe you would do that." He said, "What are you here for?" I said, "Drug court." And he was like, "Did you get in a fight or anything?" And I was like, "No sir." He was like, "What the hell, y'all? I mean, why didn't anyone tell any type of psych-- Have you even seen anybody?" I was like, "No sir." And this is all like, I'm under anesthesia at this point, talking to this guy. His name is Dr. Gunderson. He was really, really nice. He was really nice to me. But nobody can believe-- they're like, "We don't know. It's just what Judge Williams told us to do." The officers are feeling guilty. They're like, "We don't know. It's just what the order said."
他说：“我不敢相信你会这么做。”他说：“你因为什么进来的？”我说：“毒品法庭。”他说：“你打架了吗？”我说：“没有，长官。”他说：“到底是怎么回事，你们？为什么没人叫心理——你甚至见过谁了吗？”我说：“没有，长官。”这一切发生时，我已经打了麻醉剂，正在和那个医生聊天。他叫冈德森医生。他真的、真的很好。他对我很好。但没人敢相信——他们说：“我们不知道。这只是威廉姆斯法官告诉我们要做的。”警官们觉得有罪恶感。他们说：“我们不知道。这只是命令上写的要求。”
There's some things in this story that I cannot confirm. Dr. Jeff Gunderson declined my request to check out the facts of what Lindsey said about him and what he said. I can't confirm that her medication ran out and it was impossible for her to get a refill. I can confirm that Lindsey's drug court counselors did not visit her in jail, though. I was told that it's standard operating procedure in Judge Williams's drug court not to provide any treatment or counseling or even AA or NA meetings in jail, even though the National Association of Drug Court Professionals guidelines say they should.
这个故事里有些事情我无法证实。杰夫·冈德森医生拒绝了我的要求，不愿核实关于他和林赛所说的内容。我无法证实她的药物是否断了并且不可能获得补充。但我确实能证实林赛的毒品法庭辅导员没有去监狱探视过她。我被告知，威廉姆斯法官的毒品法庭的标准操作程序是不在监狱里提供任何治疗、辅导甚至互助会会议，尽管全国毒品法庭专业人员协会的指导方针说他们应该这么做。
In files at the jail and at the courthouse, I did find Judge Williams's order sending Lindsey into indefinite detention. Quote, "Until further order of the court." But nothing specifying solitary confinement. A jail official told me that it would be unusual-- but not unheard of-- for the judge to order that kind of thing. If Judge Williams hadn't ordered Lindsey into solitary, the only other way that she could have ended up there is if the jail's disciplinary committee held a hearing and put her there. I asked the jail to check and see if she had come before the disciplinary committee in October 2008. They told me that this raised privacy issues and that I needed to get Lindsey to sign a notarized document giving them permission to release this information. Lindsey is currently in a prison halfway across the state, so it took some doing to get a document to her and signed and notarized from behind bars.
在监狱和法院的文件里，我确实找到了威廉姆斯法官把林赛送去无限期拘留的命令。原文是：“直到法庭另有命令。”但没有规定单独监禁。一位监狱官员告诉我，法官下令做那种事虽然不寻常，但也并非闻所未闻。如果威廉姆斯法官没有下令让林赛单独监禁，她最终会待在那里的唯一可能就是监狱纪律委员会举行听证会并将她关进去。我要求监狱核实她是否在2008年10月出现在纪律委员会面前。他们告诉我这涉及隐私问题，我需要让林赛签署一份公证文件，授权他们发布此信息。林赛目前在全州另一端的监狱里，所以拿到一份让她在狱中签署并公证的文件费了不少功夫。
But I managed that. When I presented this document to the Sheriff's office, which runs the jail, I was told that Sheriff Wayne Bennett had decided that although the notarized document from Lindsey would allow him to give me the information that I wanted, it did not mandate that he give it to me. So he did not. Lindsey's family did confirm that she tried to kill herself, that they got called with this news when it happened. Two and a half years later, Lindsey still has scars.
但我做到了。当我把这份文件交给负责监狱管理的治安官办公室时，我被告知韦恩·贝内特治安官已经决定，虽然林赛的公证文件允许他向我提供我想要的信息，但这并不强制他必须给我。所以他没有提供。林赛的家人确实证实她曾试图自杀，当事情发生时他们接到了电话。两年半后，林赛身上仍有伤疤。
Umm, those two are there.
嗯，那两个还在。
The right one looks OK. The left one you could still see two big--
右边那个看起来还好。左边那个你还能看到两个大的——
Yeah, they're better today than they were. My hand shook really bad from where I guess, I nicked some type of nerve. I don't do it real bad anymore. Just barely.
是的，今天比当时好多了。我的手颤抖得很厉害，大概是因为我伤到了什么神经。现在抖得没那么厉害了。只是轻微地。
I don't know. They're shaking.
不知道。它们在抖。
Yeah, I mean they shake, my wrists do, but--
是的，我是说它们会抖，我的手腕会，但是——
And did the counselors know that you had a history of cutting?
辅导员知道你有自残史吗？
Yes. Yeah. They did.
知道。他们知道。
And did Judge Williams know?
威廉姆斯法官知道吗？
Yeah.
知道。
If they didn't know, they were missing out on some crucial information about her. The counselors and Judge Williams also had to know about any antidepressants Lindsey was on because the drug court contract specifies that they had to approve any medications that she used. And, according to court records, Lindsey had been on suicide watch before, two years before, on August 15, 2006. In spite of this, somebody ordered her into a cell for months, in isolation.
如果他们不知道，那他们就错失了关于她的一些关键信息。辅导员和威廉姆斯法官也必须知道林赛服用的任何抗抑郁药，因为毒品法庭的合同规定他们必须批准她使用的任何药物。而且根据法庭记录，林赛两年前，即2006年8月15日，曾被列入自杀观察名单。尽管如此，还是有人下令把她关进牢房几个月，处于隔离状态。
Coming up, Brandi, the girl who slipped ramen noodles to Lindsey, she has got quite a story too. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio on Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，布兰迪，那个偷偷给林赛送拉面的女孩，她也有个很长的故事。稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台带给你，我们节目继续后请收听公共广播国际。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today we're devoting our entire show to the story of one judge and one drug court. The judge is Amanda Williams, Chief Judge of the Superior Court of Glynn County, Georgia. She runs the drug court programs in Glynn, Camden, and Wayne County. And she runs them very differently than other drug court programs around the country.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们整场节目都在讲述一位法官和一个毒品法庭的故事。这位法官就是阿曼达·威廉姆斯，佐治亚州格林县高等法院的首席法官。她负责格林县、卡姆登县和韦恩县的毒品法庭项目。她运营这些项目的方式与全国其他毒品法庭大相径庭。
One big way they're different? They pull in way more offenders than other drug courts. In 2009, according to the Georgia Department of Audits and Accounts, the Glynn and Camden County drug courts, run by Amanda Williams, were the biggest drug court operation in the state of Georgia. The biggest, with 378 participants. That is 48 more participants than the drug court in Fulton County. Fulton County contains the city of Atlanta. Fulton County has 10 times the population of Glynn and Camden Counties combined, yet its drug court was smaller. So what's Judge Williams doing to nudge so many people-- such a remarkably high number of offenders-- into drug court?
有什么很大的不同吗？他们吸纳了远比其他毒品法庭更多的罪犯。根据佐治亚州审计和会计部的统计，2009年由阿曼达·威廉姆斯负责的格林和卡姆登县毒品法庭是佐治亚州最大的毒品法庭行动。最大的，有378名参与者。这比富尔顿县的毒品法庭多出48名参与者。富尔顿县包含亚特兰大市。富尔顿县的人口是格林县和卡姆登县总和的10倍，但其毒品法庭却更小。那么威廉姆斯法官在做什么，能把这么多的人——如此惊人数量的罪犯——推向毒品法庭？
This was back in December of 2005.
那是2005年12月的事了。
You may remember Brandi Byrd, the young woman who stood on the toilet and had shouted conversations with Lindsey Dills in the Glynn County jail. How she ended up in drug court is a story that begins one night when she was out with friends.
你们可能还记得布兰迪·伯德，那个在格林县监狱站在马桶上与林赛·迪尔斯隔空对话的年轻女子。她如何进入毒品法庭的故事要从她某晚和朋友出去玩说起。
And my friend got pulled over for DUI. He was driving. They asked to search the car and my belongings, and I told them they could. I told them that I didn't have anything. Well, when they searched my purse, they found two Darvocets which were my mother's.
我的朋友因酒驾被拦下。他在开车。警察要求搜查汽车和我的物品，我告诉他们可以。我说我什么都没带。结果，当他们搜查我的钱包时，他们发现了两片我母亲的达沃西特（Darvocet）。
Here's how they got there. Brandi and her family all say that a few months before, Brandi had an operation to remove some precancerous cells that could develop into cervical cancer.
这就是它们出现在那儿的原因。布兰迪和她的家人都说，几个月前，布兰迪做了一次手术，切除了一些可能发展成宫颈癌的癌前细胞。
And I didn't have health insurance. So my mom had actually given me a couple pills to take instead of me filling my script for my own pain medicine. I never took them, so they were still in there. And I meant to give them back to her but it just slipped my mind. I had them in an Altoids Mint thing in my pocketbook. So when they found them, they asked me what they were and I told them that they were Darvocets and they belonged to my mom. I didn't realize they were in there. And they told me, "Well you know this is a felony drug charge." I said, "No, I didn't."
我没有医疗保险。所以妈妈给了我几片药，让我吃，而不是让我去补开止痛药的处方。我从来没吃，所以它们还在那里。我打算还给她，但忘了。我把它们装在口袋里的薄荷糖盒子里。所以当他们发现时，问我那是什么，我告诉他们那是达沃西特，是我妈妈的。我没意识到它们在里面。他们告诉我：“嗯，你知道这是重罪毒品指控吗？”我说：“不，我不知道。”
Well, they arrested me and I called my grandma, because I wanted to be bonded out. Well, then they told me, you do not have a bond until you see Amanda Williams. If you're arrested for a felony drug charge, you don't have a bond until you go before the judge. Most places, it's if you get arrested you have a bond immediately unless you're on a probation violation or, of course, if it was murder or something like that you would have to wait to go to court.
嗯，他们逮捕了我，我给祖母打了电话，因为我想保释。结果他们告诉我，在见到阿曼达·威廉姆斯之前，你没有保释金。如果你因为重罪毒品指控被捕，在你见到法官之前，你没有保释。在大多数地方，如果你被捕，通常会立即有保释金，除非你有缓刑违规，当然，如果是谋杀或其他类似情况，你可能需要等待出庭。
That's actually a pretty good summary of the way it works in most courts in Georgia. Brandi's somebody who wishes that she could be a lawyer. She's got a head for it, too.
这确实是佐治亚州大多数法院运作方式的准确总结。布兰迪是个希望自己能成为律师的人。她也很有这方面的头脑。
So I freaked out about that. Just the fact of, I was stuck in jail and couldn't bond out.
所以我因为那个崩溃了。仅仅是因为我被困在监狱里，没法保释。
In Glynn County, you wait in jail on any drug charge to the next day that drug court cases come around. And it's just once a week. So Brandi sits in jail for six days before she's put in front of Judge Williams. She was charged with two felony counts, one for each pill. Darvocet is a Schedule IV drug under Georgia law. It's her first offense. She's 22.
在格林县，任何毒品指控你都得在监狱里等到毒品法庭案件开庭的日子。那是一周一次。所以布兰迪在被送到威廉姆斯法官面前之前，在监狱里坐了六天。她被控两项重罪，每片药算一项。在佐治亚州法律下，达沃西特是第四类管制药物。她是初犯。她22岁。
OK, quick reality check. What would she get elsewhere in the state? Again here's Parag Shah, criminal defense attorney in Atlanta.
好，快速核实一下现实情况。她在州内其他地方会得到什么判决？再次邀请亚特兰大的刑事辩护律师帕拉格·沙阿。
And she has no record?
她没有犯罪记录？
No, no record.
没有，没记录。
I would say in most courtrooms, that would be dismissed, either through an affidavit or testimony, or the mother saying that she gave it to the daughter.
我会说在大多数法庭上，这会被驳回，要么通过宣誓书，要么通过证词，或者通过母亲证明是她给了女儿药。
Worst case, he says, she'd be found guilty and then get probation, and then at the end of it have her record wiped clean. Bruce Harvey, who does drug cases around the state, agreed.
他说，最坏的情况是她被判有罪，然后缓刑，最后犯罪记录清零。在全州处理毒品案件的布鲁斯·哈维表示同意。
What, for having two pills?
什么，就因为两片药？
Yeah.
是的。
Are you kidding me? I can't imagine that it would get anything but first offender probation.
你在开玩笑吗？我无法想象这除了初犯缓刑外还能有什么判决。
Some counties, he said, might do a pre-trial diversion, send you to drug class for 16 weeks. Penny Penn, the District Attorney for Forsyth County, says in her county they would consider somebody like Brandi for pre-trial diversion or for the drug court.
他说，有些县可能会做审前分流，送你去参加16周的毒品课程。福赛斯县地方检察官佩妮·佩恩说，在她的县，他们会考虑让像布兰迪这样的人参加审前分流或进入毒品法庭。
And if the person didn't go into drug court, then it would probably be a probation case. It's hard when you're dealing with such a small amount.
如果当事人没进入毒品法庭，那么这很可能就是一个缓刑案件。当你处理这么小剂量的案件时，这很难。
OK. That's most places in Georgia. Here's what happened in Judge Williams's courtroom. After six days in jail, no bond permitted, Brandi goes before the judge. Brandi's grandmother, Ann Harris, who raised her, came to court too. She told me she knew Judge Williams before all this.
好。佐治亚州大多数地方都是这样。以下是威廉姆斯法官法庭上发生的事。在监狱里待了六天，没获准保释，布兰迪出现在法官面前。养大布兰迪的祖母安·哈里斯也来到了法庭。她告诉我她在这之前就认识威廉姆斯法官。
She was the judge in Brandi's adoption. I always thought very highly of her at the time.
她是布兰迪收养案的法官。当时我一直觉得她评价很高。
But once they got to court, the message from everyone was the same. The public defender told Brandi, a drug court official told Mrs. Harris--
但一旦到了法庭，每个人传达的信息都是一样的。公设辩护人告诉布兰迪，毒品法庭的一名官员告诉哈里斯夫人——
If Brandi did not go into drug court, that she would go to prison. Because that was two felonies.
如果布兰迪不参加毒品法庭，她就会进监狱。因为那是两项重罪。
And the drug court counselors were there. And they told me, "You're going to go to prison for one to five years if you don't do this program." I mean, that scared me. Because first of all, I've never been in trouble. And the thought of  me going to prison--
毒品法庭的辅导员也在那儿。他们告诉我：“如果你不参加这个项目，你就要进监狱服刑一到五年。”我的意思是，那吓坏我了。因为首先，我从来没惹过麻烦。想到我要去坐牢——
We were more or less-- we were threatened. I mean, we were scared of what would happen.
我们或多或少——我们受到了威胁。我的意思是，我们很害怕会发生什么。
From the bench, according to the court transcript, Judge Williams tells Brandi that her options are to go to trial, and if she's found guilty she'll get a year in detention plus four years probation. Judge Williams tells her that that's the minimum sentence her court gives on any drug charge. In a detention center, Brandi asks. Yeah, Judge Williams says. In a lock down detention. It's called a boot camp or, then the assistant district attorney jumps in, quote, "Where you pick strawberries all day. I mean, if you eat one, you'll get in trouble."
根据法庭记录，威廉姆斯法官在法官席上告诉布兰迪，她的选择是接受审判，如果被判有罪，她将被判一年拘留加上四年缓刑。威廉姆斯法官告诉她，这是她法院对任何毒品指控判处的最低刑期。布兰迪问是拘留中心吗？是的，威廉姆斯法官说。在封闭式拘留中。它被称为新兵训练营，或者，然后助理地方检察官插话道：“在那里你整天采草莓。我的意思是，如果你吃一颗，你就会惹麻烦。”
Elsewhere in the state, as you've heard, Brandi would get probation for this offense. But Judge Williams tells Brandi that she doesn't give straight probation in her court. Quote, "There's no such thing as putting you on probation. If you don't beat the rap, there's no street probation for charges in this county and hasn't been for seven years, since I've had drug court." She tells Brandi that if she doesn't choose drug court and wants to go to trial instead, it's a $15,000 bond to get out of jail. That's the standard bond she gives everyone. Former public defender in Glynn County told me that's high enough that most drug court defendants can't afford it.
正如你所听到的，在该州其他地方，布兰迪会因为这起罪行获得缓刑。但威廉姆斯法官告诉布兰迪，她的法院不提供直接缓刑。她说：“没有把你放在缓刑期这回事。如果你不赢下案子，这个县的指控就没有街头缓刑，我运营毒品法庭这七年来一直没有。”她告诉布兰迪，如果她不选毒品法庭而想接受审判，保释金是15000美元。这是她给每个人的标准保释金。格林县的一位前公设辩护人告诉我，这个数额太高了，大多数毒品法庭被告都负担不起。
I think people are being coerced into going to drug court.
我认为人们正在被强迫进入毒品法庭。
This is attorney Mary Helen Moses, one of the team of lawyers in Glynn County trying to unseat Judge Williams. She was the candidate who ran against the judge in the fall election.
这是律师玛丽·海伦·摩西，格林县试图让威廉姆斯法官下台的律师团队成员之一。她就是秋季选举中与法官竞争的候选人。
A first time drug offense in Glynn County carries with it a $15,000 minimum bond. That's incredibly high.
格林县的第一次毒品犯罪附带最低15000美元的保释金。这高得离谱。
Why? What's it compare to elsewhere?
为什么？和其他地方相比如何？
Oh, I'd say first time offenses, maybe $3,000, maybe $3,500. But I think what ends up happening is you've got a judge saying, "OK here, you can post a $15,000 bond or you can go into drug court and be released on your own recognizance. You can come before me in a trial on your drug charge. And it looks pretty bad to me, and if I find you guilty you're going to have a minimum sentence." I mean, that's an awfully hard thing, not to accept drug court under those circumstances.
哦，我会说第一次犯罪，大概3000美元，可能3500美元。但我认为最终发生的情况是，有一位法官说：“好吧，你要么交15000美元保释金，要么进入毒品法庭，你可以被自行释放。或者你可以在毒品指控审判中出现在我面前。在我看来这情况很糟，如果我判你有罪，你将面临最低刑期。”我的意思是，在这种情况下如果不接受毒品法庭，那是非常艰难的。
So in Judge Williams's court, there's no probation for anybody, even first offenders. No bond before you come in front of her. Then a $15,000 bond after you see her. A minimum sentence of 20 to 24 months in detention for most offenses, 12 months for minor ones. We couldn't find any drug court in Georgia that does anything like it to prod people into their programs.
所以在威廉姆斯法官的法庭上，对任何人都没有缓刑，即使是初犯。在你出现在她面前之前没有保释。见到她之后又是15000美元的保释金。对大多数犯罪判处20到24个月的最低拘留期，较轻的则是12个月。我们找不到佐治亚州有哪个毒品法庭会这样促使人们参加他们的项目。
Because drug court is supposed to be voluntary. If you push the wrong people in, you'll doom them to failure. And even though most drug courts create incentives to lure reluctant addicts into the programs, it's important that the defendants feel that they have a free choice to enter or not.
因为毒品法庭应该是自愿的。如果你把错误的人推进去，你就会注定他们失败。即使大多数毒品法庭会创造激励机制来诱导不情愿的成瘾者参加项目，让被告感觉到他们有自由选择参加或不参加的机会依然很重要。
I really didn't know what else to do. I didn't want to stay locked up. And I felt like if I did not get into drug court, then I would be sent to prison.
我真的不知道还能做什么。我不想被关着。我觉得如果我不进入毒品法庭，我就会被送进监狱。
Again, Brandi Byrd.
同样是布兰迪·伯德。
And they told me that if I did not admit to using drugs and having a problem, then they would not admit me into drug court. So basically I told them what they wanted to hear. There was a counselor from drug court that came in and gave me a test and asked me about my drug use. And of course I told them, "OK, yeah I've done this and I've done that." But once I got into drug court I explained to them, "Look I did this so I wouldn't go to prison."
他们告诉我，如果我不承认吸毒并承认有问题，他们就不会让我进入毒品法庭。所以我基本上告诉了他们他们想听的话。毒品法庭的一名辅导员进来给了我一个测试，问我关于我吸毒的事。我当然告诉他们：“好吧，是的，我做过这个，做过那个。”但一旦我进入毒品法庭，我就向他们解释：“听着，我这么做是为了不进监狱。”
As you'd expect, that didn't go down so well. Take Brandi's very first counseling session, a group session with about 20 other women.
正如你预料的那样，这结果并不好。看看布兰迪的第一次辅导课程，一个有大约20名女性的小组会议。
You're supposed to introduce yourself, what your charges are, and what your drug of choice is. I introduced myself. I told them what my charges was. I said, my drug of choice, "I smoke marijuana." I said, "But I'm charged with these pills and I'm not guilty of it. They were my mom's. I'm not a drug addict." And they just laughed about it and said I was in denial.
你应该介绍你自己，指控是什么，以及你选择的毒品是什么。我介绍了自己。我告诉了她们我的指控是什么。我说，我选择的毒品是：“我抽大麻。”我说：“但我被指控这些药，我没罪。它们是我妈妈的。我不是瘾君子。”她们只是笑，说我否认事实。
But you could see why the would laugh. Because everybody who comes in to a--
但你能看出她们为什么笑。因为每个进来的——
Yeah. And  I understand that. I still didn't fit in with the people that were there. You know, the stories you hear in there of people giving their testimonies and things they've done, and how far along they were in their addiction. Shootin' up, selling their bodies for drugs, stealing from their families. I've never stole from my family. They said that my addiction just hadn't advanced that much because I hadn't sold my body for crack or drugs. I've never done crack. I never did any kind of heavy drug.
是的。我理解。我还是不合群。你知道，你在那儿听到的关于人们提供证词的故事，她们做过的事，以及她们吸毒到了什么程度。注射、为毒品出卖肉体、从家人身上偷钱。我从来没从家人身上偷过东西。她们说我的毒瘾还没发展到那个程度，因为我没为了快克或毒品出卖肉体。我从来没抽过快克。我从没用过任何烈性毒品。
Which brings up another question. Should a first time offender like Brandi-- or Lindsey for that matter-- be in a drug court program at all?
这就引出了另一个问题。像布兰迪这样初犯的人——或者林赛——到底应不应该参加毒品法庭项目？
Well I mean, we certainly know that drug court works best for the most seriously addicted and most criminally involved offenders.
嗯，我的意思是，我们当然知道毒品法庭对那些最严重的成瘾者和犯罪参与度最高的罪犯效果最好。
Again, West Huddleston, former drug counselor and coordinator. Now the head of the National Association of Drug Court Professionals. When he describes the target population for drug court, note how different it sounds from Brandi, who  only signed up because Judge Williams, her drug court employees, and the public defender made her feel she had no choice.
还是韦斯特·赫德尔斯顿，前毒品辅导员和协调员。现在是全国毒品法庭专业人员协会的负责人。当他描述毒品法庭的目标群体时，注意一下这听起来与布兰迪有多么不同，布兰迪仅仅是因为威廉姆斯法官、她的员工和公设辩护人让她觉得别无选择才加入的。
Those individuals that drug court works best for have long histories of addiction, have multiple treatment failures, have been on probation multiple times, have probably served previous jail or prison sentences, but all driven by their addiction. If that's not the population that a drug court is seeing, then they're truly not going to have as good outcomes.
毒品法庭效果最好的那些人，有着长期的成瘾史，多次治疗失败，多次缓刑，可能服过之前的监禁或刑期，但所有行为都是由毒瘾驱动的。如果毒品法庭看到的不是这类群体，那么他们确实不会有好的结果。
And he says that when people who don't have long histories of addiction and criminality are thrown into a program that is designed for people who do-- these intensive treatment programs with all their monitoring and curfews and consequences--
他说，当没有长期成瘾史和犯罪史的人被扔进一个为那些人设计的项目时——这些密集的治疗项目伴随着各种监控、宵禁和后果——
What happens is, they can become very defiant. Because it's too punitive. It's like, if you're too punitive with your child, they will become defiant.
会发生的是，他们可能会变得非常反抗。因为它太具惩罚性了。就像是，如果你对孩子太具惩罚性，他们就会变得反抗。
I have no way to judge whether or not Brandi Byrd was truly an addict. But she was a low-level offender and she absolutely became defiant. She didn't obey the terms of her drug court contract. Never bought in. Continued to drink. Got picked up on a DUI. Was sent to inpatient treatment, fled it, vanished from the program for 11 months, and eventually was kicked out. And then, served time for the two felony counts on the two Darvocet. Which was 20 months in detention. She just got out this December. She still has three years of probation, including regular drug tests. She's not allowed to drink, either.
我没法判断布兰迪·伯德是否真的有毒瘾。但她是一个低水平的罪犯，而且她绝对变得反抗了。她没遵守毒品法庭合同的条款。从未真心投入。继续酗酒。因酒驾被抓。被送往住院治疗，逃跑了，消失了11个月，最终被踢出项目。然后，她为那两片达沃西特的两项重罪服了刑。那是20个月的拘留。她去年12月刚出来。她还有三年缓刑，包括定期药检。她也不被允许喝酒。
You know, I can admit that I made a mistake and that I violated the terms. But that much time for two pills? And I just felt like my whole life had just been snatched out from under me.
你知道，我承认我犯了错误，违反了条款。但就两片药判那么久？我觉得我整个人生都被毁了。
It's important to note here that many people get through Judge Williams's drug court just fine. When I visited the court one day this fall, she didn't yell at anybody. If anything, she was encouraging, like an unusually maternal high school coach. Wandering up to people during the break, I met a guy named Perry Burton, who's been in and out of the drug court program for four years. He told me that when he first started, quote, "I hated that lady. I hated that lady from the bottom of my heart. But she got me off drugs. She's helped me more than anyone. She's got a heart. She's brought me close to my kids."
这里值得注意的是，许多人顺利通过了威廉姆斯法官的毒品法庭。今年秋天我有天去法院参观时，她没对任何人吼叫。如果非要说有什么不同，她是在鼓励，就像一个不寻常的、带有母性的高中教练。课间我游走时，遇见了一个叫佩里·伯顿的人，他在毒品法庭项目里进进出出四年了。他告诉我，他刚开始时：“我恨那个女人。我从心底里恨那个女人。但她让我戒掉了毒品。她帮我比谁都多。她有一颗心。她让我和孩子们亲近了。”
Even Judge Williams's opponents say that she's doing what she thinks is best for drug court participants. She believes in tough love, that people need to be woken up. And when I spoke with Judge Williams this fall, she also made it clear that she thought her drug court was no different from any other.
即使威廉姆斯法官的反对者也说她是在做她认为对毒品法庭参与者最好的事。她相信严师出高徒，人们需要被唤醒。当我今年秋天与威廉姆斯法官交谈时，她也明确表示，她认为她的毒品法庭与其他任何法庭没什么两样。
All drug courts function just like this. My drug court is based on national drug courts. All of the forms that I use come from national drug courts. All of the methods that we use come from national drug courts. And what I do is exactly what other people in other drug courts have done for years and still continue to do.
所有的毒品法庭功能都像这样。我的毒品法庭是基于全国毒品法庭的。我使用的所有表格都来自全国毒品法庭。我们使用的所有方法都来自全国毒品法庭。而我所做的正是全国其他毒品法庭多年来一直做并继续做的事情。
My best guess is that this was completely sincere. At the time she probably believed that. When I later learned otherwise, and sent her details about how her court was different, and asked for an interview about those differences, by then she'd stopped answering my calls. As for her success rate, this fall the drug court's clinical director, Steven Mansfield provided me with numbers showing that the graduation rate for the Glynn Camden drug courts was 48%. Below the national average and way lower than successful programs. Low enough, one expert said, it showed something was going wrong.
我猜这是完全真诚的。当时她可能相信这一点。当我后来了解到事实并非如此，并将她法庭与其他法庭的不同之处发给她，并要求就这些差异进行采访时，那时她已经不回我的电话了。至于成功率，今年秋天毒品法庭临床主任史蒂文·曼斯菲尔德提供的数据显示，格林和卡姆登县毒品法庭的毕业率为48%。低于全国平均水平，远低于成功的项目。一位专家说，这么低足以显示出哪里出了问题。
When I shared that information with the National Association of Drug Court Professionals and they approached Judge Williams about it, she provided them with different numbers, showing a 54% graduation rate, which isn't as good as the best programs, but it's on par with the national average.
当我与全国毒品法庭专业人员协会分享该信息，他们就此接触威廉姆斯法官时，她向他们提供了不同的数据，显示毕业率为54%，这虽然不像最好的项目那么好，但与全国平均水平持平。
There's one more case I want to share with you. And it's somebody who, unlike Brandi or Lindsey, went into drug court willingly.
我还想和你分享另一个案例。这是一个与布兰迪或林赛不同，自愿进入毒品法庭的人。
I was 19. I was just before turning 20, and into things I shouldn't have been into.
我当时19岁。刚要满20岁，接触了一些我不该接触的东西。
In May of 2001, Charlie McCullough went with some friends to a motel room to buy drugs, in Charlie's case LSD, and they were caught in a police sting. He got the same treatment that you've heard about. He was told that he needed a $15,000 bond to get out of jail, or he could do drug court and be released right away. Drug court seemed like a good deal.
2001年5月，查理·麦卡洛与一些朋友去汽车旅馆买毒品，在查理的案例中是LSD，他们在一次警方的钓鱼执法中被抓获。他得到了你听说过的那种待遇。他被告知需要15000美元保释金才能出狱，或者他可以选毒品法庭并立即获释。毒品法庭看起来是个不错的交易。
I remember desperately wanting to get out of jail. It seemed like a good thing. I'd get to go to this counseling. And then-- I did want to do better, you know? And I figured if something like that, I was going to be monitored pretty much 24-7, it'd be more of an incentive to do the right thing.
我记得极其想离开监狱。这似乎是件好事。我会得到这种辅导。然后——我确实想表现得更好，你知道吗？我觉得如果像那样，我会被24小时监控，这会成为做正确事情的动力。
So Charlie enters the drug program, quits drugs. He'd been smoking pot every day, he says. And he liked Judge Williams.
于是查理进入了毒品项目，戒掉了毒品。他说他以前每天抽大麻。而且他喜欢威廉姆斯法官。
I'd say all in all it was a good experience. And going to court, she sees this growth in you and she compliments on it. First impression, a great person. A really nice lady. I mean, my first two years, I was an advocate for the program. I was all for it. It felt like I turned a new leaf. And I did. I changed a lot about myself. I was happy the way things were going.
总体来说这是个不错的经历。去法庭时，她看到了你的成长并为此称赞。第一印象，一个伟大的人。一个非常好的人。我是说，前两年，我是这个项目的倡导者。我全力支持。感觉我改过自新了。确实如此。我改变了很多。我对事情的进展感到满意。
Drug court is set up with four separate phases.
毒品法庭设有四个独立阶段。
This Charlie's lawyer, Jim Jenkins. He's one of the few lawyers who's ever come before Judge Williams who would talk to me on tape. And the reason that he did it is that he's a private attorney who does not live in Glynn County. Most of his practice is elsewhere. He says Charlie did great in the program.
这是查理的律师，吉姆·詹金斯。他是极少数愿意在录音带上与我谈话的出现在威廉姆斯法官面前的律师之一。他这么做是因为他是一位不居住在格林县的私人执业律师。他的大部分业务都在别处。他说查理在项目中表现极好。
He was in the final phase of the program. He was just three months short of graduation. And he was called in for a random urine screen, which they do regularly in the program.
他处于项目的最后阶段。距离毕业只差三个月。他被叫去参加一次随机尿检，这是项目中经常进行的。
I went in there and I took the drug test. She said that it came up positive for methamphetamine.
我进去了，做了药检。她说结果显示甲基苯丙胺呈阳性。
She, the drug counselor, not Judge Williams.
她，毒品辅导员，不是威廉姆斯法官。
I knew I wasn't messing around. So I told her that wasn't right. They let me take another drug test.
我知道我没胡闹。所以我告诉她那不对。她们让我做了另一次药检。
So she took another sample and gave him another test.
所以她又取了一个样本，让他做了另一次测试。
And we should say this was just like, 20 minutes after the first test.
我们应该说这大概是在第一次测试后的20分钟。
Within 20 minutes. Exactly. And it came out negative.
20分钟内。完全正确。结果是阴性的。
They took a third test. Same result.
她们进行了第三次测试。同样的结果。
And I passed it. I was under the impression when I left that night that, no big deal.
我通过了。我离开那天晚上时印象中是，没什么大不了的。
You know just like sometimes there's a false positive, just some little mistake.
你知道就像有时会出现假阳性，只是小错误。
Right.
对。
And he talked with the drug counselors about this. And they were really on his side. Because Charlie had done absolutely perfectly for 22 months in the program and never had a bad screen, had never missed a meeting. In fact, he was such a good student that he mentored other participants. And he'd actually appeared in front of the county commissioners, asking them to allocate more money for the drug court program because it was such a great program.
他和毒品辅导员谈过这个。她们确实站在他这边。因为查理在项目中22个月表现完美，从没有过糟糕的检测，从没缺席过会议。事实上，他是个模范学生，甚至指导其他参加者。他甚至出现在县专员面前，请求他们为毒品法庭项目分配更多资金，因为这项目太棒了。
The next week it was a day when all the Phase Four participants were supposed to attend drug court.
第二周，那是所有第四阶段参与者被要求出席毒品法庭的日子。
And they say I've got to go in front of the judge for the drug test I failed. And that was a big shock to me. I told her, I didn't fail the drug test. I passed the second one. And she said that she was going to use the first one, that the second one didn't count.
她们说因为我没通过药检，必须站在法官面前。这对我来说是个巨大的打击。我告诉她，我没药检失败。我通过了第二次测试。她说她要使用第一次的结果，第二次的不算数。
And he tried to explain to her and it goes back and forth with that. And Charlie finally says, "Your honor, may I speak please?"
他试图向她解释，事情反反复复。查理最终说：“法官大人，我可以发言吗？”
Actually do you want to read what he says there?
其实你想读一下他说的话吗？
Sure.
好的。
It's page two of this transcript from March 11, 2003.
这是2003年3月11日法庭记录的第二页。
Charlie says, finally says, "May I speak?" The court says, "yeah." And Charlie says, "I have no explanation for that at all. I don't. 20 minutes later I took another test. It was tested three times. I passed that, OK? I can't explain to you why. All I know is what I've done and what I haven't done, your honor." And her response to that is, "Well, you know, I don't believe you." Then it goes back and forth and they talk about the tests--
查理最后说：“我可以发言吗？”法庭说：“可以。”查理说：“我对此没有任何解释。真的没有。20分钟后我做了另一次测试。测试了三次。我通过了，好吗？我没法向你解释为什么。我所知道的只有我做过什么，没做过什么，法官大人。”她的回应是：“嗯，你知道，我不相信你。”然后事情反反复复，他们讨论这些测试——
Right, apparently one of the workers there named Alicia grabbed the cap for the little vial of pee from the trash--
对，显然那儿的一名工作人员艾丽西娅从垃圾桶里抓走了那个尿液小瓶的盖子——
Right.
对。
And then Judge Williams says, "Now I don't believe that in a heartbeat." And Charlie says, "Ask Alicia. She'll tell you. She will not lie in court. She grabbed it out of the trash can."
威廉姆斯法官说：“现在我完全不信那一套。”查理说：“问艾丽西娅。她会告诉你的。她在法庭上不会撒谎。她是从垃圾桶里抓出来的。”
And then Charlie says, "I'm not going to go 22 months with clean time and then three months from my graduation to use." And Judge Williams responds, "Well people have done it."
然后查理说：“我绝不可能在保持干净22个月后，在离毕业三个月时使用它。”威廉姆斯法官回应：“嗯，人们确实会那样做。”
Judge Williams asked Charlie to take a polygraph and Charlie says, "Sure." And then she does not give him a polygraph. Alicia is not called as a witness to settle this question about the lid. And then, Judge Williams sentences Charlie to 17 days. In Charlie's treatment file it explains that the 17 days is comprised of two things.
威廉姆斯法官让查理做测谎仪，查理说：“好的。”然后她并没有给他测谎。艾丽西娅没被叫来作证以解决关于盖子的问题。然后，威廉姆斯法官判处查理17天监禁。在查理的治疗档案中解释说，这17天由两部分组成。
It was comprised of 3 days for having a bad drug test result and it was 14 days for questioning the result.
它由3天不通过药检结果和14天质疑该结果组成。
Wait, wait. He got 14 days simply for saying, like, no, no, I don't think this is right.
等等，等等。他仅仅因为说“不，不，我觉得这不对”就被多关了14天？
Because he questioned the result.
因为他质疑结果。
Wait, but what law was he violating there? Isn't that what court is for? Isn't he supposed to-- isn't this the place where he's supposed to be able to say, let me tell you my side. Now you decide?
等等，但他违反了什么法律？法庭不是为了这个吗？他不是应该——这不是他应该能说“让我告诉你我这一边的情况。现在你来决定”的地方吗？
Not this court. Not this court. If you question this court you get punished for it. And in this situation, because he questioned what was going on, he got 14 days extra in jail.
不是这个法庭。不是这个法庭。如果你质疑这个法庭，你就会因此受到惩罚。在这种情况下，因为他质疑正在发生的事，他多坐了14天监狱。
In any drug court, that would be an unusually long penalty. 17 days for a first bad drug screen. But Charlie was also sent back to Phase Two of the program, which meant that he would be spending an extra year and a half in Judge Williams's drug court. His time in drug court just suddenly jumped from two years to three and a half.
在任何毒品法庭，这都是非常漫长的处罚。第一次药检失败罚17天。但查理也被送回了项目的第二阶段，这意味着他将在威廉姆斯法官的毒品法庭额外多待一年半。他在毒品法庭的时间突然从两年跳到了三年半。
Judge Williams freely admits that she gives harsher sentences to anybody who denies doing drugs when a drug test says they've done them. In fact, most drug courts do that. But we couldn't find one drug court that would levy so harsh a penalty on a first failed screen.
威廉姆斯法官毫不避讳地承认，对于任何在药检显示吸毒后否认吸毒的人，她会判处更重的刑罚。事实上，大多数毒品法庭都这样做。但我们找不到一个毒品法庭会对第一次药检失败开出如此沉重的罚单。
And the question that is raises is the most uncomfortable question people raise about Judge Williams. Is she just a hothead? Somebody who can't stand to be contradicted. Somebody who overreacts when argued with. And is that affecting her rulings? This came up in the fall elections. Jim Jenkins says that what's clear is that any drug court judge has unusual powers, powers most judges do not have and needs to wield them fairly.
这就提出了关于威廉姆斯法官最令人不适的问题。她只是个急躁的人吗？一个受不了被反驳的人。一个在被争论时反应过度的人。这影响了她的判决吗？在秋季选举中这被提出来过。吉姆·詹金斯说，显而易见的是，任何毒品法庭法官都拥有不寻常的权力，这是大多数法官没有的，并需要公平地运用它们。
Now if somebody were unhappy with their treatment in the drug court, can they just appeal it? I mean usually in a court--
如果有人对他们在毒品法庭的待遇感到不满，他们能上诉吗？我是说通常在法庭上——
No.
不能。
No? Why not?
不能？为什么不？
There is no provision at all for any kind of appeal, and that's one of the other real problems with the procedures of this particular drug court. If Judge Williams sentences you to 30 days or an indeterminate sentence, there is nothing that can be done. Period. You can't appeal to the court of appeals. There's nobody to go to.
完全没有针对任何上诉的条款，这也是这个特定毒品法庭程序问题的真实痛点之一。如果威廉姆斯法官判你30天或无期拘留，你什么都做不了。没门。你不能向法院上诉。你没人可找。
And is the reason why there's no right to appeal because basically I've already pled guilty to my charge and so--
而且没上诉权的原因是因为基本上我已经为我的罪行认罪，所以——
That basically it. And you're in a treatment program. And these are sanctions that are supposedly designed to foster your treatment.
基本上就是这样。而且你是在治疗项目中。这些都是据说旨在促进你治疗的制裁手段。
In fact, I've seen orders that Judge Williams has issued where she instructs a 22-year-old woman to move in with her grandmother and grandfather, the people who apparently turned her in to the authorities in the first place, and, quote, "Follow any rules of their household." She ordered the same woman, Alyssa Branch, to go to a doctor and, quote, "Upon attending her medical appointment, defendant shall comply with all recommendations of Dr. Gowen. Should further medical procedures become necessary, defendant shall undergo said medical procedures." And on June 9, 2010, the same woman, Alyssa Branch, is ordered to inpatient treatment for a year at a place called Bridges of Hope with, quote, "No outside visitation passes, no visitation to the facility from any outside persons, and no contact with any outside persons." If this woman wished to contest any of these judge's orders, Jim Jenkins believes, she has no recourse.
事实上，我见过威廉姆斯法官签发的命令，指示一名22岁女性搬去和祖父母同住——那些显然最初把她告发给当局的人——并“遵循他们家庭的任何规则”。她还命令同一位女性，阿丽莎·布兰奇，去看医生，并“在参加医疗预约时，被告应遵守高文医生的所有建议。如果需要进一步的医疗程序，被告应接受所述医疗程序。”而在2010年6月9日，同一名女子阿丽莎·布兰奇被判入驻一个叫“希望之桥”的地方进行为期一年的治疗，原文是：“不得有任何外界探视许可，不得有任何外界人士前往该设施探视，不得与任何外界人士接触。”吉姆·詹金斯认为，如果这名女子希望对这些法官的命令提出异议，她没有任何诉诸途径。
Here's something else. When you enter Judge Williams's drug court she requires you to sign a piece of paper saying that no matter what happens, you won't go to any other judge but her. You won't recuse her. This also goes against the guidelines of the National Association of Drug Court Professionals. I know I'm saying that a lot this hour. If a person is in danger of being terminated from drug court, and that person wants another judge to take the case at that point, they're supposed to get it. Because at that point, the thinking is, the drug court judge knows too much personal information about the client to be an unbiased and impartial judge.
还有一件事。当你进入威廉姆斯法官的毒品法庭时，她要求你签署一张纸，说无论发生什么，你都不会去找除她以外的任何其他法官。你不会要求她回避。这也违反了全国毒品法庭专业人员协会的指导方针。我知道这一小时我说了好多次这个。如果一个人有被终止参加毒品法庭的危险，且该人想让另一名法官处理案件，他们本应该得到这个机会。因为到那时，思维是，毒品法庭法官了解当事人太多的个人信息，无法成为不偏不倚的法官。
And so in cases like Brandi Byrd's, when she was terminated from drug court, another judge might have looked at the facts, the two pills, all that, and waived some of the 20 to 24 month sentence that Brandi agreed to as a condition of entering drug court. Brandi's lawyer tried to get Judge Williams to at least give Brandi credit for the four and a half months she served in jail waiting for her termination hearing. Sometimes Judge Williams chooses to do that. Here she doesn't even consider the possibility. In the court transcript Brandi's attorney says, "Can she get credit for time--" He doesn't even finish the sentence. He doesn't even say the word served. The judge says, "No sir. She does not. Let's go to the next case."
所以在布兰迪·伯德这类案件中，当她被终止参加毒品法庭时，另一名法官可能已经查看了事实，那两片药等情况，并免除布兰迪作为进入条件同意的20到24个月刑期中的一部分。布兰迪的律师试图让威廉姆斯法官至少给布兰迪计入她在监狱等待终止听证会期间服刑的四个半月时间。有时威廉姆斯法官选择这样做。这里她甚至没考虑可能性。在法庭记录中，布兰迪的律师说：“她能得到服刑时间计入——”他甚至没说完句子。他甚至没说“已服”这个词。法官说：“不能，先生。她得不到。进行下一案。”
In Charlie's case, being told that he'd now be spending three and a half years in the program instead of just two, when he was so close to finishing and he'd never missed a meeting or failed a previous drug screen, it had exactly the result that research studies show is the problem with an overly punitive approach. It made him rebel. It made him give up. The harshness of Judge Williams's sentence took a model participant and turned him into a failure.
在查理的案例中，在已经接近毕业且从未缺席会议或药检失败的情况下，被告知现在要在项目里待三年半而不是两年，这带来的后果与研究表明的过度惩罚性方法造成的问题完全一致。这让他反叛。让他放弃。威廉姆斯法官判决的严苛把一个模范参与者变成了一个失败者。
Once that day came it was a big-- it was like a big slap in the face. Everything I had pretty much put my trust into, kind of turned its back on me. I sat here and I dedicated 22 months of my life to changing it. And I felt like everything I had done was for nothing.
一旦那天来临，这就是一个巨大的——就像在脸上狠狠扇了一巴掌。我几乎把信任寄托的一切都背弃了我。我坐在那里，把两年的生命奉献给了改变。我觉得我所做的一切都白费了。
And then December that year, you get screened positive for marijuana.
那年12月，你药检大麻呈阳性。
Yeah. You know, yeah. I'd smoked some pot. By that time I was over it. I didn't really care. I was just disappointed, extremely disappointed.
是的。你知道，是的。我抽了些大麻。到那时我就不干了。我真的不在乎。我只是失望，极度失望。
A month later he missed his first group meeting and a warrant was issued for his arrest. It took him four years to get out of the program. He's clean now and doing great. He has a wife and two kids, lives in Virginia, builds bridges for a living.
一个月后，他缺席了第一次小组会议，法庭对他发出了逮捕令。他花了四年才从项目中出来。他现在戒了，表现得很好。他有妻子和两个孩子，住在弗吉尼亚州，以架桥为生。
As for the other two, Brandi's still adjusting after two years in detention. Working in a restaurant, trying to earn some money, get her life together. Lindsey gets out of detention this May. And she'll finally be through with the drug court program, though she has four and a half years of probation still. She's planning to do it up in South Carolina near her mom. She has a job lined up and a fiancee, and they're going to try to have a baby. The first time in years she has something she's looking forward to.
至于另外两个，布兰迪在拘留两年后仍在适应。在餐厅工作，试图赚点钱，把生活过下去。林赛今年五月出狱。她终于要完成毒品法庭项目了，尽管她还有四年半的缓刑。她计划在南卡罗来纳州她妈妈附近完成。她找好了工作，还有了未婚夫，他们打算要个孩子。这是多年来她第一次有值得期待的事情。
Her one fear is that Judge Williams will hear that she talked to me for the radio and do something punitive, like tell her to do her probation back home in Glynn County. In Glynn County, she says, so many people she used to do drugs with are still there. It's always been harder for her to stay clean. If the judge were to force her to stay there, she'd be setting her up for failure.
她唯一害怕的是威廉姆斯法官听到她为了广播和我谈过话，然后做点惩罚性的事，比如告诉她回格林县完成缓刑。她说在格林县，她以前一起吸毒的许多人还在那儿。她一直很难保持清醒。如果法官强迫她待在那里，她就是在诱导她失败。
In his inaugural address this January, Georgia's new governor Nathan Deal made a big point of calling for more drug courts as a way to reduce the number of people behind bars and save money. His son, Superior Court Judge Jason Deal, runs the drug court in Hall County. Drug Courts have become one of those nonpartisan solutions that everybody, from the Republican governor of Georgia to the Democratic President of the United States, says they love. But as drug courts expand into more places and become more of a standard part of the criminal justice system, it's possible that they're changing.
在今年一月的就职演说中，佐治亚州新州长内森·迪尔明确提出了呼吁建立更多毒品法庭，作为减少入狱人数和省钱的一种手段。他的儿子，高等法院法官杰森·迪尔，负责霍尔县的毒品法庭。毒品法庭已经成为一种非党派的解决方案，从佐治亚州的共和党州长到美国民主党总统，每个人都说他们爱它。但随着毒品法庭扩展到更多地方，并成为刑事司法系统的标准组成部分，它们可能正在发生变化。
One of leading researchers on drug courts, Steven Belenko-- he's been doing studies on them for 20 years; he's a professor of criminal justice at Temple University-- told me there no studies on this yet, But anecdotally he's noticing drug courts are becoming more punitive and more controlling.
毒品法庭的领先研究人员之一，史蒂文·贝连科——他研究它们已经20年了；他是天普大学的刑事司法教授——告诉我目前还没有相关研究，但传闻中他注意到毒品法庭正变得更具惩罚性，更具控制欲。
Over time what's happened, drug courts have become routinized. So you see judges who are just kind of rotated into drug courts. And I've certainly talked to and heard about judges who were put into drug court who really have no interest or knowledge about addiction, addiction treatment. Not to criticize them at all. They're just not trained or invested in this model. So I think they take with them kind of the more typical judicial responses of, if you violate a judicial order you're going to be punished.
随着时间的推移，毒品法庭已经变得例行化了。所以你看到法官只是被轮换到毒品法庭。我当然和那些被安排到毒品法庭却对成瘾、成瘾治疗毫无兴趣或知识的法官谈过，听过他们的故事。并非批评他们。他们只是没有受过训练或对此模型投入。所以我认为他们带入的是一种更典型的司法回应，即如果你违反了司法命令，你就会受到惩罚。
According to the National Association of Drug Court Professionals, about 150 of the nation's drug courts do not apply the principles of the drug court model correctly and are not having good outcomes as a result.
根据全国毒品法庭专业人员协会的统计，全国约150个毒品法庭没有正确应用毒品法庭模型的原则，导致没有好的结果。
[MUSIC - "CARE OF CELL 44" BY THE ZOMBIES]
[音乐 - “CARE OF CELL 44” BY THE ZOMBIES]
Eric Mennel helped me with the reporting for today's program.
埃里克·门内尔帮助我完成了今天节目的报道。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Special thanks to Nancy Updike for taking over as host for the radio show while I finished the reporting for today's program, and to our show's senior producer, Julie Snyder, for running the show so beautifully when I was gone. Our other producers, Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semian, and Alissa Schiff. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman's filling in as our West Coast producer. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
特别感谢南希·厄普代克在我完成今天节目的报道时接任广播节目的主持，以及我们的高级制片人朱莉·斯奈德在我离开时如此完美地运营节目。我们的其他制片人：亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米安和阿丽莎·希夫。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。简·伯曼担任我们的西海岸制片人。《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, before he got a job in radio, he had a show that he did for his own family, transmitted only in their house, which isn't hard.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板，托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道，在他获得广播工作之前，他曾为自己的家人做过一个节目，只在他们家里传播，这并不难。
You just stand up on the toilet or the sink and get to the air vent and talk through it, and they can hear you.
你只要站在马桶或水槽上，够到通风口，隔着它说话，她们就能听见。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带给你更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。